That we've witnessed innocent people
being slaughtered on an industrial scale
in Syria.
My feeling is now one that you cannot
allow an armed mafia to take revenge on
an entire country without allowing some
protection for civilians.
Now what that kind of protection might
take is something that we have all
Assyrians debated very painfully.
It's not an easy thing to say with the
example of Iraq fresh in our mind that
yes,
we do want military intervention,
but I think what we do absolutely need
our safe corridors that would enable
families of displaced persons to reach
safety without being killed.
We would need safe corridors for
defectors.
The reason we don't have the kind of
detection on a large scale from the army
is because the price of defection is
intolerably high and it's not just the
people that affect your shot.
When people hear the phrase safe
corridor,
think who could be against safe corridor
was,
it sounds wonderful,
but to do that,
to enforce it will mean heavy duty and
that what will others that are not in
the room now worn is that that will mean
a huge unleashing of the kind of blood
boil.
Well,
we already have a blood bath of.
Yeah.
Can I,
I want to get in on this because I want
to know just how it felt when you were
there that moment when you were an
attack,
but even before then when you saw people
being.
Did you yourself think the only way to
solve this is the outside world has to
act?
Absolutely.
It's one thing,
I guess seeing it from a distance to be
involved in it,
to watch it,
to watch people dying for a piece of
bread,
the risks people were taking just to
feed themselves.
Um,
there is no option.
You know,
they are a well trained army,
but it was actually pointed out to me by
many military defectors,
high level military defectors that the
Syrian army is a big,
powerful arm.
It's also not an army that is actually
trained to fight was whether the army as
an army base,
there are several suppression of
civilians,
so when it comes to taking out,
as would be the case if we're to create
safe and safe havens,
they're.
They're not such big guys when it comes
to that.
They're very good that I'm surrounded
civilians and killing them.
In other words,
what the kind of remedies that Michael
Weiss has application application using
the price wouldn't be so unbearable.
Absolutely.
I think that,
you know,
we,
we overestimate the scale and the size
of the city and capability to fight back
when it is an army and civilian
population.